today my question for you what's your
approach of turning and tragedy into
triumph it doesn't necessarily have to
be with one specific thing in life but
just in general when something goes bad
what's your take on how you so
super-quick what's the tragedy right now
I am on academic probation
and I am serving a one-year suspension
in college I'm 50 credits away from
getting my my undergraduate degree but
my situation is that I'm on academic
probation I'm serving a one-year
suspension and right now I have no job
no car so the only thing that I can do
is start literally from the bottom my
parents do help me so I know that that's
a plus but I'm 21 so I'm trying to break
free of that dependency upon them you
know because it's that time for me I
have to you know carry my own weight and
I'm trying to find my way in this
process so from your perspective what do
you feel like is the best approach are
you gonna try to like you want to go
back to school after the one year you
want to go back or you are you you feel
like you're done absolutely I'm going
back I have to made a promise to my
parents I'm gonna keep my word got it so
listen I'm a big believer that your
purpose comes from your pain you know I
think that if you go through something
really negative and you come out the
other side then it'll fill you up so
much to be able to help others go
through that same thing you can help a
lot of people like if you go through
this this next year how tough it's gonna
be if you go through it and you get a
job and you you make your way through
and like I want to make my mom proud and
you you take the year you eat it and you
go back and you graduate you'll be able
to have a message to help other people
in the same situation on them overcoming
it and staying staying on the path and
don't quit on your education like if
that's something you believe strongly in
I can't share that story I went to
university I finished I didn't drop out
but I never got academic probation this
is never my my problem my issue so I
could talk in general about hey I think
I think keeping your goals is important
and I finished my you know undergrad
education but I can't it's not a truth
for me so people won't listen to me but
they'll listen to you because it's your
truth getting through it and recognizing
that I am gonna solve this problem and
I'm gonna solve it not just for me but
I'm gonna I'm then gonna inspire the
people I'm gonna I'm gonna lift people
up with me I'm gonna climb that
staircase and I take the next step and
I'm gonna reach down I'm gonna pull
people up with me you have the power to
do that I think people are good I think
humans are good I think I'm on Team
human and I think whenever you've
struggled with something you then want
to make the path easier for other people
it's just human nature I think it's just
that's who we are that's what we want to
do we want to make the path easier for
the next generation and so when I see a
struggle what I try to do is think about
how amazing this is gonna be when I
struggle with something even today like
minor struggles today I set a goal to go
I wanted to play basketball for an hour
outside I lasted 15 minutes I missed my
first 15 judges my shoes broke I had to
go to the community center and ask for
duct tape to put them back together and
and I had to go home but on Wednesday or
tomorrow filming Thursday any gap I'm
going to do it again with better shoes
and I'm gonna miss you know 14 shots
instead of 15 and I'm gonna keep going
on that journey and so that's not as big
a loss as you know being kicked out of
school and being on academic probation
for a year but I've had big losses in my
life too I was struggling being an
entrepreneur why do I love helping
entrepreneurs so much is because I
struggled so much looking at my life now
when the money I've made and the
lifestyle I relate more still to the
people who are starting up I remember
not being able to afford a full meal at
McDonald's and just ordering french
fries like I remember that I still I
resonate more with those people than
than the people who were flying high
making tons of cash I don't I don't I
feel like those people are kind of
disconnected from reality and so that's
why I love
helping entrepreneurs so much is why I
put so much love into this into my
youtube channel into all the work that
I'm doing because it was so painful for
me now at the time and going through it
I wasn't thinking this is gonna be my
mission I'm gonna help other
entrepreneurs I just thought wow this
sucks like I hate my life but fast
forward any pain any struggle that I go
through now that's what I tell myself
like if this becomes a big pain a big
struggle and I get through it I'll be
able to help other people with the same
thing it builds your own self-respect
every time you get faced with a struggle
and you grow from it it builds massive
self-respect if you as an example if you
go through this moment here and if you
did quit you would feel terrible the
rest of your life you feel you're a
quitter
you'd feel you're a loser you feel you
let your mom down you feel like you set
a goal he didn't hit it you would feel
terrible you it would Road your
self-confidence and self-respect even if
other people told you hey don't worry
it's okay you would still have an eroded
level of self-respect but if you do it
you get through it you struggle you find
your way you're your self-respect will
grow will rise will boost every time you
get faced with a difficult problem and
you you try to solve it and you don't
give up you don't quit it raises your
self-respect you've set a goal you have
to do it yeah there we go
stoic elite what's up man I hear you
talking a lot about schedule and I heard
the other day you say that you have like
specific days of the week that you
attribute to something so like I heard
you said one day is from mentor day and
I was wondering if you can kind of go
through your weekly schedule of what day
you associate to what there are some
things that I do daily and some things
that I do weekly so my morning routine I
do daily Instagram live I could do daily
Thursday I do it on YouTube but I like
this daily show is daily but apart from
that everything else is weekly so Monday
is mentoring day mentoring Alex
mentoring Lily mentoring local
entrepreneurs mentoring people on my
team and that's that's basically the
full day mention people too
YouTube day so today's Tuesday YouTube
day for me right now I'm spending my
time reviewing videos recording videos
doing the top tens Wednesdays project
day so every Wednesday slightly
different it might be my book day it
might be whatever project that I want to
get done it's like my time to work on
whatever I want to work on and what I'm
trying to do is not not just go into
email not just get not get bogged down
by admin stuff it's like this is I want
to move the ball on something creative
today so now it floats we take from
different projects but I want to move it
significantly forward and not just get
bogged down as administration
Thursday's public-facing day for me so
I'm doing podcasts and interviews and
hangouts and meetings and it's always
just jam-packed full of connecting with
other people
most of people write to me and say hey
can we have in your podcast or hey can
you contain a view from my show or for
my magazine or whatever and so my
assistant books them all back to back to
back on Thursday and then Friday is my
CEO day so all the tasks that that kind
of needs to get done in my business as
well as moving other projects forward a
lethal Friday and that's it I design
around me so why do I do that one I like
to miss films right so so like today's
you today I'm not gonna touch it until
next Tuesday and I'm gonna miss it now
and next Tuesday I like missing it okay
right I like I like like I can't wait
for this to happen again I like having a
little bit of anticipation and missing
it all so it's about my personality
where I'm not I don't like switching
gears too much if I'm deep in writing
book mode I don't want to have to go to
an interview and then come back and
write in my book I have a I think
everybody has switching costs time but I
have a really hard time switching yeah
I'm not so that's why I like having
everything done in one day awesome I
love the way you schedule in there yeah
so that's what I do and then like
weekends to weekends as you know
Saturday is is always with the family
I'm always planning something for us to
do my wife loves food every weekend I
have to find a new restaurant
or a new food or something new in the
city for her to try cuz she loves that
so I take as much care and concern on
that is on the business side too and the
sunny ends up being just like family at
midday you know we got to clean
something up we got to take care of
something but but we don't touch that on
Saturday like gotta go grocery shopping
not Saturday you know you gotta we gotta
we gotta fix something or buy a new
cabinet or whatever not Saturday right
they it all gets put your Sunday
Saturday's our data enjoying have fun I
love that I love that you have a system
for all of it because I think once you
get the system right everything else
kind of falls into place right yeah and
it's changed you know it's evolved
little micro evolutions with time but
it's just picking what works for you you
know I like the daily and I like having
something that I miss and I like being
in the zone on projects but that may not
work for everybody else right yeah when
you're not in the flow it's helpful to
get up and know like it's also I need to
get everything done for YouTube today
like I'm not touching until next Tuesday
so I'm forced to be productive because
there's so much stuff that I have to get
done for the channel to grow and I
condense it all down for one day so if
I'm slacking like this is my break my
break is doing an IG live and then I'm
back to work yeah if you want to know
what myself and other successful
entrepreneurs think about how to build
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every morning
for the next 250 for mornings I will
send you a video that is 30 seconds to 5
minutes long absolutely for free that as
you watch them it'll help you build
unstoppable confidence check out the
link in the description below surround
yourself with greatness if you want to
be more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before if you're
doing work that you love you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it
altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so
I wanted to think and see it's a bloody
brief life all of you have the potential
for enormous success if you want to know
what Gary v-d-j khalid oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video